i have thousands and thousands of
clothes i think i have like 30 000
pieces
i've never seen anything like this
before
it's a sight to see kim kardashian
revealing her over-the-top wardrobe
archive on who lose the kardashians
i'm just hoping honestly to find a
little bit of inspo today because i have
so much stuff and i've had so many
different fashion eras i love seeing all
this stuff so i just want to see kind of
where i've been and where i want to go
that's like the biggest flex ever just
archive from my own warehouse
and i just want to wear sweats
it's so crazy
during the tour kim takes a trip down
memory lane and gets candid about how
she's struggling to find her fashion
identity amid her split from kanye west
oh that's like my biggest insecurity
is finding out what my next muse
relationship is gonna be like when it
comes to my style i mean i've always had
kanye there as like this crutch to
teach me so much about fashion and
having that knot be there as my crutch
to like guide me
has really forced me to figure it out on
my own
one thing the skim sounder is sure of
any given outfit she's worn in the past
down to the smallest detail okay how
about new year's eve las vegas which
year
white gucci dress what silver my hair
was like this i was skinnier than ever i
remember that it was newly single dark
shadow and like it was like right after
chris humphries i remember i thought i
was on fire wait did you have a bang
that night
i did i don't know how you're gonna top
that
the 41 year old reality star admits she
was ready to move on from her marriage
to yay and now she's dating funny guy
pete davidson
what's your favorite thing about him um
he's just super genuine
and it's just really fun to just
hang out and do nothing and
watch tv and just do nothing
[Laughter]
and things between the couple have been
heating up
last month they made their red carpet
debut at the white house correspondents
dinner and turned heads at the met gala
[Applause]
and while we don't know if pete has any
influence on kim's new fashion era he's
keeping her happy and has the family's
approval what do you all love about pete
i love that he's kind
and really really thoughtful he's the
most thoughtful person
and i love yeah and i love the chemistry
that kim and him have together it's
really sweet i thought you said the
chemistry it was like okay chemistry
chemistry
[Music]
you